for lisa and jesse expecting the  unexpected has been an early marriage  mantra for us to be able to come out of  a pandemic and be getting married is  really exciting ending one chapter and  beginning a new one together  well heather when my wife and i got  married 30 years ago we had a saying to  get through all the tension which is  ride the wave  of whatever  it's worked for you it has and this is  how long ago this was we  we rented  cell phones  i didn't know you could do that well  this is when it was the bricks oh yeah i  remember those we felt so cool hey honey  i'm getting my are you getting your  dress i'm getting my tuxedo  but that's not why you called it is  still super windy out there gusts up to  30 miles an hour